more material more classified has been
found at a second location from
President Biden's time as vice president
this follows the news on Monday that
documents Mark classified were found in
an office Mr Biden used before he ran
for president Adriana Diaz was first to
report that Discovery and she joins us
from Washington Adriana good morning
good morning Vlad CBS News has learned
new documents marked classified were
found at at least one additional
location we don't know where that second
location is or what was found there a
source tells us that the president was
informed of the initial discovery of
sensitive documents which included
briefings and some highly classified
material at the Penn Biden Center on
November 2nd the day they were found the
White House didn't disclose that
information until this Monday more than
two months later after questions from
CBS News GOP leaders are alleging a
double standard five months after the
FBI executed a search warrant at former
president Trump's Mar-A-Lago home that
yielded over a hundred documents marked
classified Trump refused multiple
requests to return those documents for
more than a year in Mr Biden's case the
White House says proper protocols were
followed when asked about the initial
materials found at the Penn Biden Center
which were turned over to the National
Archives the day after they were found
and the justice department was notified
immediately the White House has yet to
address the second location when those
documents were found and how the top
Democrat and Republican on the Senate
intelligence committee have called for
an official damage assessment Nate
Adriana thank you